[Musique]
vous pensiez qu'on avait tout vu en
matière de remèdes maison pour
soi-disant guérir ou prévenir la comédie
19 et bien non ça continue vous avez été
nombreux à nous signaler l'existence de
cette publication partagé plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de fois sur
facebook depuis le début de la pandémie
et qui affirme qu'il faut manger des
aliments alcalin pour se protéger contre
la corée 19 avant de poursuivre sur
cette publication un petit rappel des
aliments dits alcalin ou sans acidité
c'est quoi ben c'est entre autres
certains fruits et légumes des
tubercules frais des noix des
légumineuses et peu ou pas de viande et
de produits laitiers
l'acidité l'alcalinité se mesure sur
l'échelle du ph qui varie entre 0 très
acide à 14,13 alcalin fin de parenthèse
revenons maintenant la publication
virale qui laisse entendre que le ph du
cornât virus varie entre 5,5 à 8.5 et
qu'il faudrait ingérer davantage
d'aliments alcalin le message affirme au
passage que les avocats ont un ph de
caisse des riches et les pissenlits un
ph de 22,7 et souvenez-vous les chaînes
dth elle s'arrête à 14
c'est entre autres ce qui fait
sourciller le nutritionniste bernard
laval est interrogé par mon collègue des
fillettes
autre incongruité selon lui l'idée qu'on
puisse modifier le ph de notre système
en mangeant des aliments alcalin est un
mythe
il précise que sun jamais été validées
par la science
oui plusieurs études se sont penchées
sur le sujet mais elles n'ont pas pu
établir de lien entre la consommation
des aliments et le ph de notre sens ce
n'est pas tout toujours selon bernard
laval et modifier le ph de son organisme
aurait de graves conséquences sur la
santé pour le nutritionniste notre corps
est fait pour fonctionner un certain ph
il faut donc toujours que le sang reste
un ph stable si le ph du sang se
mettaient à trop augmenter ou à trop
diminuée s'amènera des hospitalisations
de l'avis de bernard laval et vous
voulez plus de détails sur cette
publication trompeuse aller consulter
l'article de mon collègue des fillettes
sur notre site web
et n'oubliez pas de nous suivre sur
notre
facebook salut
[Musique]